[Music]
all right let's go to maven in tampa
florida hey maven what's up
hello how's it going great how are you
i'm pretty good excellent what's up
um
i'm having some
issues in my personal life and i decided
to ask for help i am proud of you and
thanks for thanks for giving me a shout
what's up how can i help
so
i have been diagnosed with um bipolar
disorder type 2 okay adhd ptsd and
borderline personality disorder
all by the same
psychiatrist um
no so my psychiatrist and my therapist
are working as a team to help me out so
it's
it's my team
okay so the team has just given you
all four of these diagnostics
um technically it was a team effort
between me and them because i wanted to
um figure out
what i have that's affecting me so i
could find coping mechanisms
and like
ways to
implement things in my life so i could
do things like a normal person
okay
i'm smiling because
i'm not a normal person and i never i
never want to be one but i do understand
what you're coming from um so take take
the diagnostics let's put them over to
the side for a second what are some
things that are going on in your life
that you want to change that you want to
be different or that would make makes
you feel unnormal
um
[Music]
i can't work a nine to five
um not right now how come it's been like
two and a half years
it really
hurts my mental health it makes me
suicidal
it makes me feel like
depressed
and like i i can't do it
what about so
um
i wanna be careful with this can we can
we experiment for a second is that cool
yeah sure okay
um
there are legitimate i cannot okay like
i cannot i cannot and i get that what i
like to do when i'm struggling with a
cannot
is i like to shift that language too
my body is choosing to
and the reason i love that is because
can't feels final to me like i can't
climb up a like a wall like spider-man
that's a thing like it's a limitation i
can't do
and so i always know that when i come up
to a wall i gotta find a way around it
or find a door
but when it comes to i can't work i
always want to shift that to i could
right now my body's choosing
not to
because that allows me to say why is my
body making that choice what is it about
not working that is keeping me safe
keeping things quiet what is it that
work
does to my body or being around other
people or that pressure what is it that
my body's saying i gotta opt out of
you see the difference there one of
those is really empowering it's an
adventure let's go find it and the other
is
i'm incapable i can never
um
it's just gonna hurt like this forever
you see what i'm saying yeah so let's
shift the language again this is a pure
experiment um i don't know enough about
your situation and i'd never be able to
know you as well as your psychiatrist
and your psychologist do but i want to
shift it to let's change it to
empowering language so for the last two
and a half years your body's chosen to
not work how come what is it about work
that makes you suicidal makes you
exhausted makes you what is it about
about work
um
i think it's the rigidity
if that's the right word the boundary um
it's like
you
have to be
in this place
for eight hours okay and you are not
allowed to leave you're not allowed to
walk out of this this premises
and you have to stay here
and work and do what we tell you to do
for eight hours
so it it almost feels like a heavy one
of those anxiety blankets it's weighing
it's suffocating
it is very suffocating does it work to
shift and say
for eight hours i get to be here and
for an exchange for my eight hours of
being here and doing like putting candy
on the shelves or solving this this
algorithm on the computer
you give me money
it's like it would work if it was
something i liked okay i tried to use
that okay um mental
like just reframing helper yeah yes but
it didn't work for a long time like i
worked in a krispy kreme
for a few months um
that's literally literally an assembly
line right right
it was awful yeah okay so let me ask you
this
who in your life
where and given your list of diagnostics
and maybe multiple places or it may have
been very very severe
somebody
or some group of people
held you under water
you have been trapped before whether
it's in an abusive relationship or a
unsafe place like you have been in it
before
so much so that your body has put a pin
in that feeling and anybody anywhere
that tries to quote unquote trap me
even if it's
something as benign as
hey this is the shift for work
we'll set that alarm off so loud that
you have to plug both ears and go like
we've you know i've been in a building
where the fire alarm goes off i got to
plug my ears because i can't i can't do
i'm my brain's gonna explode right
when did that happen to you
um i had a really bad experience in the
military and it supposed to subsequently
um led to an abusive relationship
so you you're a veteran
yes are you a combat veteran
uh no okay um what'd you do in the
military
um i was a thirty-five fox as an
intelligence analyst yeah
so you know better than
any non-veteran would know about
rigidity and rules and boundaries and
regulations right
yeah what about before that before the
military
i was
normal like i had signs of adhd but
yeah it was more normal
a lot of my diagnoses come from
can we can pinpoint it to things that
happen to me in the military okay okay
so
what i like to do in these moments and i
know we're not even to your question yet
is
the diagnostics are fine they help name
the dragon right
yeah what i always want to know is what
is my brain trying to protect me from
um there's even a famous psychiatrist
that went as far to say
disassociated like our my brain is
imagining other voices my brushing brain
is imagining dragons as a way to keep us
safe it's had to create an alt reality
because their current reality is not
safe it's abusive it's scary whatever
the thing may be
um i always want to know what is
happening like what is my body trying to
protect me from because not always but
the body's such a brilliant mechanism by
which to take care of us right until it
gets off the rails and the things it's
doing to take care of us end up making
us sicker or hurting our relationships
or whatever
so anyway yeah um thank you for sharing
that with me um
hmm
that's a heart you've gone through a lot
yes
and beyond going through a lot
now your body is so highly attuned to
other threats that may come that it's
assigning threats to things that really
aren't threats
and yeah have you reached that level
where you are anxious about being
anxious
yeah
and that's that's that's hell on earth
right that's suffering with with
with no redemptive value right yeah um
it's just sitting in a in a spinning
like you're sitting inside of a top
right it won't quit
um
so what is your like tell me your
question question
so um
one of my favorite things to do is
look online for other people
who
um
suffer from the same things i do and see
like what hacks they have for life or
like what things they do to keep them on
track to
like keep their house clean or
work or like you know do something
throughout the day
and there's not a lot of like
help with the combo of bipolar and adhd
so i'll try something that works for
someone with just adhd and just bipolar
and sometimes it works because sometimes
i'm just feeling those symptoms
but for the days that i'm feeling both
symptoms
the things don't work anymore
describe your
um bp2
symptoms the hypomania like what
describe that
um so when i'm just feeling bipolar i
have hypomania for like three
days two or three days okay
and
i get bouts of energy i'm on top of the
world
i'm like the greatest and i can do
anything
and then the depression comes for my
depression lasts
for
like
two or three weeks okay
when i'm not like when i'm medicated
okay when you are medicated
yeah when i'm unmedicated um it lasted
for two years can pull you down in the
abyss okay all right and so how does a
how does adhd factor into that
um
when i
feel just adhd a i have hyperactivity
i speak a lot i forget my things i like
i will start doing something and then it
will remind me of something else that i
have to be doing so quit doing that
thing and then move on to another thing
and then move on to another thing
i have no idea what you're talking about
i don't know anybody
i don't know anybody like that if you
listen to the show for more than eight
seconds you realize oh that's that guy
um yeah
okay i'm gonna tell you
the
my my initial thoughts here and
um
i wanna couch all of this that don't do
anything without talking to your
psychiatrist and you're in your
psychologist okay
let me give you the map forward for some
of these things um
for me okay
okay um
bipolar 2 is
highly highly over diagnosed as a
somebody who falls off a cliff when it
comes to depression which is very very
real it's just that black
it's just like syrup right you're just
caught in it you can't breathe and move
um
but it also can be very very real and so
i'm not gonna i don't want to be one of
those guys that's like throwing a
grenade on either side of that
conversation what i'll tell you is if
you truly have bipolar you got to take
your medication right so that's that's
square number one okay
square number two when it comes to
dealing with adhd
when i heard when you described these
things you described them as ways that
you feel things
and when it comes to borderline it's
this overwhelm my feelings are so
amplified and so powerful they're a
forest fire
and so when somebody says
um
when somebody says hey man i didn't like
this paper like this i didn't like this
article you wrote to looney
like me i'll be like ah man i really
like that i thought i worked hard on it
to someone who has true borderline
personality disorder it is a
you know what i hated this so much i
wish you weren't even alive right the
feelings are so overwhelming that's what
happened okay
it's and almost you even know this is a
disproportionate response that person's
not trying to be mean but your body is
just
right it's overwhelming yeah
and then you throw the chaos of adhd on
top of that so so here is an important
thing that i've done okay
and
what borderline people have to do
ultimately is make peace with their
feelings and act in non-accordance with
their feelings over a period of time to
where their body will recalibrate their
their feelings
and it's unmourning and it's very hard
okay
when it comes to adhd what i've had to
do for myself is stop
i have very segmented times when i
sit in feelings
but i cannot allow my feelings to
dictate what i'm doing in a given day
otherwise i will become like a kite in
the wind
and so here's an example
i don't care how i'm feeling i will
exercise every day
now i might feel like today once in a
blue moon once a month once every two
months i'm not gonna do the crazy hard
weight workout because i'm just too sore
i'm just too exhausted i was up till 2
a.m and now it's five in the morning and
it just would be dumb but i'm gonna go
for a long walk or i'm gonna ride the
exercise bike in my garage
so the debate over whether i'm doing
something is over
regardless of how i feel i'm going to do
these things
regardless of how i feel
i don't want to it's going to hurt i'm
going to get anxious i do not care those
feelings don't get a vote i will put my
clothes out for the next day before i go
to bed
i will brush my teeth and i will take a
shower every single day
whether i feel like it or not see what
i'm saying so i'm going to take a group
of core activities that i know help me
be well
and i'm gonna take feelings out of the
equation
i don't feel like going to bed you will
go to bed because if you don't sleep
everything downstream is chaos
i will and in my case i will go to work
even if it's angsty even if it's heavy i
might go for half a day i might go for
two hours because here's the trap that
that especially with depression here's
the trap
the trap is
i increasingly want to do less so that
the hurt will stop
and then your body learns i can make all
the hurts stop by doing nothing
which then makes it hard to breathe see
what i'm saying
the the damning part of it is the only
way out of it is through it
that's the only way out
and so instead of saying hey work is
eight hours of prison and torture
entrapment
i'm gonna get a job where i work two
hours a day
i'm gonna baby step my way into it
even on the days i don't feel like going
i'm gonna go and when i feel like the
walls are closing in i'm gonna breathe
deeply
and when i feel suicidal i'm going to
call my psychiatrist and say you come
talk to you
but i'm going to take that i'm going to
take the alternative off the table do
you see what i'm saying and what you're
going to find is
you're really much much stronger than
you thought
does that make sense
yeah
because it gives me a little hope you
were oh you should have
the the core strength that you have
underneath those bricks that you're
carrying in your backpack
you can squat way more than me you are
so much strong stronger than i am
so much
it's a matter of saying can i turn this
strength can i stop carrying the stuff
around and start applying the streak
strength moving forward and then instead
of just trying to survive
see what i'm saying
yeah
um
i have really really high hopes for you
i think you can do some pretty amazing
things and because you're one of the few
people that has repelled into the depths
of health your story and your ability to
help and serve and love other people
will be
amplified in a way that most people can
understand
thanks
do you believe me
i think so
okay i don't lie on the show
okay
i even got a ticket this morning on the
way to work and the guy said did you
know you were speeding and i was like
yup cause i was
right i'll tell you the truth
it's just been so hard for so long i
know i know
and
there's a moment where you make peace
with the fact that your body loves you
so much is trying to take care of you
it's a pretty amazing thing right
yeah
and then the other side of it is okay
the magic question is what am i going to
do now
one of the my biggest beefs with the the
mental health
ecosystem as it exists right now
um most of my colleagues are complaining
about meds whatever i don't complain
about that stuff in fact many times some
of the meds are magic they're incredible
um what i don't like about it is they've
told us that mental health is getting
the right thoughts in the right order
and then we'll if we can just think the
right way in the right direction then
we're going to be okay
and i'm convinced to be on a shadow of a
doubt
that yes the thinking is really
important but the action the doing is
equal if not more important
okay so i can get my thoughts in the
right order all day long
i don't care how i feel i'm going to get
up and make my wife's coffee
i don't care if i can't get out of bed i
will get up and make the coffee then
i'll go back to bed but i'm going to do
that one act of service today
you see what i'm saying
yeah so what's one or two things that
you could you would commit to
just for 30 days
i will do these i don't care how i feel
i don't care how
i'm gonna do these two things
um
well i had a manic episode the other day
and i decided on a morning and night
routine
good for you yes
hey listen there are few people in the
world who i love hanging out with more
than somebody in a manic state
um like they're the funnest and they're
so much and they're hilarious and
they're a lot and man you can make some
plans
right you make some plays yeah
i've always rearranged my entire house
too so excellent so you rearranged the
house you made a morning routine in the
nighttime routine
did you throw all the food away because
we're going full keto we're going to do
all the
pretty much
great i love it i love it i love it
so when you're in a manic state
and then you know what's coming on the
back end especially as the manic state
starts to lose steam and it gets scary
and you want to prop it up and prop it
up how do you prop it up and keep trying
to keep going
um i actually
just let myself
feel
the the crash
um okay
why i know it's coming anyways hold on
hold on hold on hold on why do you think
you're worth that crash
i don't understand the question
you think you deserve that crash
like you've thrown your hands up like
it's coming this is what i get
how come i don't really know
i guess i just kind of expect it now
because the manic episodes have been so
far and few in between it's like
well this is where we were anyway so hmm
so here's here's what what i want to
leave you with okay
my friend justin mcroberts wrote a book
um
based around his disdain for the words
it is what it is
and it's become a common refrain in our
culture that's just the way this is this
is all i'll ever be i'm always going to
be the worst thing that ever happened to
me i'm always going to be this diagnosis
i'm always going to be this
dysfunctional in this relationship etc
it is what it is
and his rebuke to that was no it's not
it is what you make it
right
and it's getting that little glimmer of
hope
and that little glimmer of
wait a minute i'm
way i've been rucking here you remember
back in basic like i've been wrecking
here with these
cinderblocks in this backpack
i need to get these blocks out of the
bag i'm going to quit carrying them i'm
going to stop
and you're going to realize how far you
can walk and how fast you can go
so your homework assignment is this
number one continue to meet with your
psychiatric psychologist okay i'm just a
dude on a podcast i'm not going to
substitute for your mental health care
but i want you to find two or three
things
manic episode low episode
adhd is running and gunning or you're
just exhausted your body is ramping
itself up and blowing all the gas out
and then it's collapsing and then it's
slowly building the gas back up and it
blows it all out again
when borderline's kicking and you are
feeling everything
i want you to come up with two or three
things that you know keep you well that
you know feel good that you know are
right
and i will do these things these small
things every day for 30 days i will take
a five minute walk
i will write one note a day to somebody
and tell them that i love them
i will
call i'm gonna get a job i'm gonna work
two hours a day
i'm just gonna work work the lunch rush
and then i'm gonna go home that's it i'm
gonna go home
i'm gonna begin practicing this new way
for my body so you can learn
hey this is the way we don't have to
keep you safe anymore this way we did
because you were in hell and we're out
now now we're surrounded by people who
love us we're surrounded by we got the
right meds we're on the right track now
we're going to begin practicing a new
way
and what you're going to find is you are
way way stronger than you could have
ever imagined
and as i end all these calls maven
if you're ever considering hurting
yourself
you got to make that call and i trust
that since you've said this in the past
that you you have made that call and i'm
proud of you
every time moving forward you will make
this call
i'm convinced like i said earlier
there's light at the end of this tunnel
pick a couple of things and keep
practicing keep stepping keep stepping
keep stepping and get those bricks out
of your backpack